earlier this year I wrote a story called
boudic green and it was about how
investors have been pouring money into
music catalogs the likes of cardi B's
bodek Yello songs like that all rolled
into one
asset and kind of the incredible thing
about these catalogs is that they're now
available to invest in in these kind of
smaller chunks so as a retail investor
you could be putting in thousands of
dollars as opposed to tens or hundreds
of thousands of dollars even millions of
dollars which used to be the minimum
barrier to entry to start to have a
stake in some of these musical assets in
the old days pretty much the only way
you could buy a piece of a song would be
to go in and actually purchase a massive
catalogue you know going back to the
days of Michael Jackson buying the ATV
publishing catalog for forty seven and a
half million dollars in the mid 80s that
was home to most of the Beatles biggest
hits these days you actually have a few
companies like royalty exchange where
they do the heavy lifting and basically
you can go in and buy a smaller slice as
Tiny as a few thousand dollars of one of
your favorite artists big songs or
catalogs I had had my eye on royalty
exchange for a while and wanted to write
about it but you know before I kind of
really dug in I wanted to make sure I
had a main character for the story and
found this guy named Alex Eva he settled
in Texas as a finance wizard basically
at a boutique investment firm and he had
a bunch of money lying around and he
didn't really want to put it all in
something that was correlated to the
stock market so as a music fan he
decided you know why not invest in
royalties and so he went through lt
exchange and actually got into modak
yellow by investing in a stream that one
of the producers are songwriters on it
had put up for auction so the funny part
about the story is that he didn't
actually know the song he just saw the
numbers on it and you know the kind of
revenue was throwing off on a quarterly
basis and decided that he would make a
jump and you know turned out to be quite
a big hit very fortunately free it's not
like cardi B's out there and you know
putting up her song on
royalty exchange or any of these
platforms necessarily more likely the
way that these assets make it to the
market is that you know on a typical pop
song or hip-hop song there could be a
handful or even in some cases dozens of
writers and producers and different
people who have credits on the song even
though their name is not on the track
when you see it pop up and Spotify or
Apple music they're getting paid for it
and they can sell all or part of their
royalty stream to that song or to that
batch of songs on one of these platforms
this model of selling world thinks is a
lot better for recording artists and
songwriters than the old model where you
hear these horror stories of you know
musicians selling their catalogs for a
Cadillac or even a bottle of wine in
this case on these services you know you
if you're a musician you can sell a
chunk of your royalty stream you can
sell you know part of an individual song
you can sell it for a set period of
years one of the really attractive
things about investing in music
royalties is that in theory they're not
linked to the overall market right so if
the Dow is crashing or the Nasdaq is
crashing it doesn't really have any
effect on how much people are gonna be
listening to music and aggregate
investing in music royalties is is kind
of a counterintuitive business because
you might think oh you want to get in
early on a song and you know ride the
wave but actually if you get in on
something like black yellow right when
it comes out you'll probably see it's
churning out you know a pretty lucrative
royalty stream in the beginning and then
it kind of Peters ass over the course of
time if you look at catalogs like
old-school Tupac songs are up there and
you know have been getting a very steady
amount of spins and thrown off a steady
amount of money for decades so not to
say that you shouldn't invest in big
songs if they come up for sale early on
but you know I think any investor
veteran type in this industry would tell
you just be wary and know that the early
returns are not the same as the longtail
returns
gonna be definitely don't go investing
all of your free cash into music
royalties or anything you know I think
you know even the most aggressive people
would only say you know like max 20% of
your portfolio but probably try to keep
it to about 10%
you